hello
thank you very much for coming to my
talk today I'm flattered that there's so
many seats taken I was expecting
something different so thank you for
that
um my talk today
um is about history over the last nine
years uh in our organization flixbus and
it's about a modernization journey and
what we've learned on our way and let me
Dive Right In
so I want to give you a quick Outlook
first of what we're going to talk about
today
um I'm going to give you a small history
tour right to understand the context
that we've been in before we started on
this kind of modernization Journey
um and then I'm going to talk about what
the actual problem was that drove us to
the decision to embark on such a journey
because it's important to know that not
all the reasons are valid
then what can we do about that very
problem
um
that's going to be the next point and
then we're going to talk about the
five-step improvement process that we
have discovered worked very well for us
um and of course I hope
it can work for you but I know that each
organizational context is different so
maybe for you it would be a six step or
seven step or four-step process who
knows
and if we have time maybe
um
a little bit of q a but if we don't you
can still catch me afterwards ask me
questions I'm a I'm a very nice guy I'll
try
answer any question you have so just
grab me afterwards
so let's start with the small History
tour
um
and uh
that's a little bit what is the
evolution of the code base so we had a
monolith
and um
you can see the numbers here right so we
started like in 2012 the market was
liberalized in 2013 the German bus
market so we started development in 2012
already the tech stack was a classic web
development stack of the time
PHP 5.2 and my SQL instance in version
5.5 and jQuery are 1.8 is anybody still
using jQuery here I'm
want to
three ah don't be shy
so in 2015
um we merged with our largest competitor
on the German Market which was flixbus
because the brand I started working with
was called my Inferno so these were the
two major competitors and we decided to
merge
um because it just makes more sense
instead of fighting each other you know
dumping the prices that you merge and
you know try to uh be a bit more Revenue
generating oriented instead of fighting
each other
um and in mid-2017 we
understood that something went wrong
or even some things went wrong
and that's when we started our our
journey so we started with 170 000 lines
of code very very small application
um and only 12 people working on the
code
um to you know 2018 where we had 175
people working on the actual code and
11.2 millions of logical lines of code
so let's talk about the architecture
um so this is
uh
uh a title of the IEEE computer magazine
no server bullet right that's the
classic Fred Brooks
article in which he describes it
um I love the cover by the way uh it
seems like some wolf is just gonna
jump out the bushes and
Ambush that woman
she already knows what's coming
um but somehow we as an industry are
very good uh inconsistently and
repeatedly coming up with new silver
bullets even though we know about this
because it's not a technical problem
it's a social problem
um we haven't solved that yet
but it's the same it was the same for us
right
so Jeopardy time so it's a little quiz
um
so who hasn't played Jeopardy before you
know there's a statement and you need to
come up with the question right so this
architecture pattern was the most widely
used software and framework architecture
for web-based projects in 2012.
so who wants to solve it
one
yeah part of it more specific
anybody
MVC who said it
there
Applause for that man
it's correct
the classic Model
view controller architecture so I have
to say nothing is inherently bad about
that architecture it's not about the
architecture I want to you know make
that clear
because it's about how about you use it
not the architecture itself you can
build very nice applications with the
MBC architecture but the Frameworks back
in that days made it very easy to make
very very bad mistakes so
whoever who doesn't know about it that's
how it works we have a model which is
like a representation of your database
schema
um that is you know delivered to
the users of your application through
view
um the user you know does something and
controller receives data manipulates the
model
and it goes back into the database right
that's it it's a kind of layered
architecture and
for us it was a good choice
it was fast to get started right as I
said there was a deadline looming the
liberalization of the market was
beginning of 2013 so you know there's a
hard deadline you need to go fast
like
there's a promise that you know you can
change all these layers independently
right so you can change the front and
independently from the controllers and
independently from the models
um so that sounded like a really great
idea back then right
you have the ability to try multiple
views you can build an HTML site you can
build CSV downloads you can build a rest
API right so you are very very flexible
within that single application to
deliver
any kind of use cases
and normally these MVC Frameworks they
came with batteries included like
routing security templating you know all
of this was there you didn't have to re
reinvent the wheel you could just use
what the framework provided and focused
on you know the features
yeah but
Houston we have a problem
it went very well we were very
successful we were growing a lot we're
making a lot of money
um and that's a curse of successful
applications
um because they grow so fast
there's often a point where you miss
changing
the way you build software you know
going from this
like Facebook said going fast and break
things towards going slower and don't
break as many things as before
but what was our problem because it
should be a business problem and not the
technical problem
often I speak to people yeah but you
know on the database we have so much
contention and you know these are the
technical it's not a technical problem
you know the organization doesn't care
if there's a technical problem the
organization does care
if you know when we don't deliver value
that a competitor is gaining an
advantage above
for us or that we're losing Customs or
that we're losing money
right that's what the business is caring
about they don't care about you know
database migrations going wrong or this
code is so messy I don't want to you
know work with it anymore that's not
really a reason so we need to focus on a
business reason and
this is basically the one metric that I
normally use to communicate that
um it's the classic lead time cycle time
reaction time and
what we
discovered was that you know the cycle
time
kept increasing
more and more
what the cycle time is is actually
development time right so developers
working on the code the reaction time is
some business analyst has an idea
and you know they discuss it there's
some Discovery and then you know okay
let's build this so that's the reaction
time there's a lot of that can be a lot
of problems with reaction time as well
I'm not saying like
but the cycle time if that is increasing
then there is something in the of the
tech in the technical side of things
right so it's not in the organization
the idea is there the feature is there
um please build it but it takes longer
and longer
and for us it kept increasing up to the
point where we were not able to actually
deliver features where we had to say
that's currently not possible I'm sorry
like we would have to change half of the
system to actually make that happen
so if you have to say that
to the people in the organization
that's a strong sign that things are
going very wrong
and that we need to change something
and that was also the case for us right
so we took that signal and uh
started to do something but before I
talk about you know how we approached
solving the problem
I want to dive first into the failure
patterns
right so what actually went wrong on the
technical side because as I said it was
not the architecture itself it was not
NBC
NBC is innocent
we are the bad guys
so the first failure pattern is anemic
domain models
the Frameworks back then made it very
easy to build these models there was
like a command on the CLI you know
you're just generating your entity
classes they have a lot of Getters and
setters
um yeah and you were basically done
right so it made it very easy to
generate these kind of data containers
um which unfortunately is the default
for or was the default for many of the
NBC Frameworks back then
so let me show you an example it's PHP
don't worry
um I think most of you probably can
understand that
um it's very easy to read if you if you
can't or if you want to have another
example fetch me later
um we have a order entity right it has
three Fields a daytime field created at
a string status and like a mutable
collection items
I know it could be designed much better
but it should just get the point across
right now
as I said we have Getters and Setters
and uh we have a get items method that
Returns the mutable collection to the
outside
and of course you have then an order
service you know that fetches the order
from the DB
um
gets the status does something some
validation some processing whatever you
know and sets the status to canceled and
saves it back to the DB
I mean this is even a little bit better
than it was five years before 2012
because that would have been all in the
controller and the controller would have
been the classic spaghetti code but
we're somewhere else
we're here
we evolved from spaghetti
lasagna
very tasty
but why are anemic models actually the
driver for lasagna architecture right
the problem is that
it's just data you know like these
entities with Getters and Setters they
don't have Behavior they're just data
containers in the end they're just
representation of your database and the
references you know and the collections
and everything and all the logic you
know the the business Logic the
important part is spread out across the
services right and you start building a
lot of these services and you get this
lasagna architecture not only in the
service service side but also on the
entity side right so
it's encapsulation done wrong so let me
just read it here the text
when the classes that describe the model
and the classes that perform operations
on the model are separate the services
contain all the domain logic while the
domain object themselves contain
practically none
right
so that was
one of our initial mistakes and you
probably have seen this chart before
um this is the classic Blood Sweat and
Tears over time chart
so here's the anemic model
right so as I said it's very easy to get
started right so yeah you get a head
start you can deliver
a lot
um but it really really gets messy very
very fast
so in comparison what I call the rich
model and we will see what that means a
little bit later but
a lot of people will tell you this is
the sweet spot right to you know change
the strategy of how you deliver code
so it's not
the really sweet spot is actually here
right
you need to know in advance like that
something goes wrong and you want to be
changing before you have that additional
cost right you want to have that
investment earlier unfortunately
I haven't seen a single organization
that has done that like that if you did
that then please talk to me and tell me
how you did it especially how you're
convinced management to do that
because it's very very hard to get that
point across
so that's where we were
I mean this this Arrow probably goes
outside of the spectrum somewhere
through Oslo
maybe even into the Norwegian sea
somewhere I don't know it's very very
long
so that was the first failure pattern
the second one
is weak boundaries
so
when I talk about that I mean there's
all the talk about modular monoliths
right now right who needs microservices
we can build modular monoliths if you
have weak boundaries in the model of a
monolith I can assure you I don't give
it two years and it will become just a
messy lump of something but not a
modular thing
so what is a weak boundary means sharing
information
among distant elements of the system
right
I mean very low cohesion if you share
information like with very close
elements you have a high cohesion that's
fine but if they are very distant
that's not fine anymore
so this is how it looked like right so
we have a use case use case a might be
cancel order might be whatever you know
something important some activity some
capability within within your
organization and you know you start you
have this order Service as I said
because we have this lasagna right we
we're talking only to the service layers
we're not talking to the model uh itself
and
we get another service now another use
case that's talking to the same service
because you know don't repeat yourself
we already have that order service why
should that new use case use something
else why should we duplicate it
there's no need
I can just reuse it
more and more use cases come
you know and these use case are very
distant right remember that I mean they
look very close on this slide but I mean
if you look like inside the organization
one might be you know a customer care
agent doing something the other might be
you know the customer on your page
making some update to their order
details or something right so very very
distant
in terms of where in the organization
these kind of changes
are created
so this thing just grows right because
what happens is
all of these use cases and distant
elements they have this slightly
different requirements right they are
not really the same they look the same
they kind of you know if you bend them a
little bit you can make them fit
but you have to add like stuff
exceptions for each of that use cases
you know a lot of conditionals that are
checking if this is an order request
from this customer service agent then do
something else then that right so it
accumulates
a lot and something we call the god
class
symptom it uh gets a lot of
well I call it like a force of physical
Force so it's gravity right so the
larger it gets the higher gravity it has
the more changes it it attracts
so like this was like Jupiter movie
maybe
and of course the other entity was
growing as well because
there were a lot of Getters and Setters
now because like we just added database
column of the database column of the
database column to also accommodate for
these new use cases right
another thing about weak boundaries and
a mistake that we did is exposing
private entity collections to the
outside
so
an example like a use case there's an
auto repository right and the use case
gets the order and
it does some changes everything is fine
you know there's a consistency guarantee
we have a transaction we save it it's
all good
but now
use case b
has an order item repository you see
that often for example in report
building right we don't need the orders
we just need the status from the order
items and stuff
back then that was we thought it was a
great idea
um obviously nowadays most of the people
know it's not
but back then
um we thought it's a great idea
um but it breaks the consistency
boundary right keeping this setup
consistent is virtually impossible
because use case a
you know does not know about use case b
and there might be a concurrent request
updating you know the order items
without the order actually knowing about
it because it's already in memory
and you start you know corrupting your
system
so another problem
so this is a path
and this path has been paved by us
Developers
right so we were doing things in a way
right we had these anemic models we had
these services
we had these weak boundaries but you
know when we were growing and more and
more developers joined the company
they were also taking that part because
you know you see where the others are
going and you follow down that path
you're not just going to go like through
the woods alone right you'd follow the
path that the others have paid for you
I call this syndrome that's how we do
things here
the classic answer to you know Juniors
asking very uncomfortable questions
foreign
because it now enters multiple positive
feedback loops right and that's why I
believe these different problems
together
accelerated themselves
so as an example like imagine it's very
messy developers very fed up you know
with the system he already like talked
to management we need to change
something ah it's it's not gonna
continue like that and you know nothing
happens he leaves the company right
new developers hired
he walks down the same path as the
others because I mean that's how we do
things here right uh but really do you
think that's a great idea yeah yeah it's
like it works you know we're generating
money our system is successful yeah
works
so
the problems get worse right because we
continue to work in that way right and
so it doesn't get better
gets worse
the developer wants to change something
talks to management hey we need to
change something I have this urgent
feeling that something is going very
wrong
and at some point that developer leaves
right and that's the circle you have I
mean we had that experience multiple
times that the people were fed up
with working in that massive system and
you know not having the possibility to
really deliver value I mean us as
developers we want
our company to be successful we want to
be part of that value delivery if we
cannot do that we're going to become
very very unhappy right also a major
driver for Burnout I mean if you uh
listen to the keynote
um yesterday I think
um then you've heard about it so a lot
of people were also like can't cannot do
them I need a year break or something
so this was repeating all the time right
and the other problems as well so the
service lasagna it all got worse State
Management was distributed everywhere
and I mean at some point the database
just said no
so much contention so much locking that
was happening there you can imagine if
you have like you know customers
you know your customer base grew by
sorry
um your customer base grew by thousand
percent or even more
you know also the strain on the system
grew and you were not able to to you
know scale up
back then it was not just oh yeah we I
have this Aurora cluster I can just you
know replace the instance that give me
like I don't know
our our 16 extra extra large or whatever
uh Amazon is having right now so back
then that was not possible we were on a
you know
bare metal servers actually running our
stuff so it was not easy to just
scale up
so
that's a summary for the failure
patterns because I mean there was much
much more that I haven't talked about
here which is testing for example right
so if you have this lasagna architecture
testing and mocking becomes super super
hard if you do it and you want to change
it later it's becoming very very hard to
change the test as well so you have an
additional layer of things that you
don't want to change
um but I mean I just have a little bit
of time to talk about these things
um so if you want to hear more stories
catch me later
again summary lasagna very hard to
change because you have so many
different places if you want to
implement a new use case you know it's
not like this single place I just make
the change you have to remember like
where it actually happens
um State Management as I said very very
hard
contention locking in the database
and the developers are very unhappy
[Music]
um
quitting
and this cycle even made the problem
worse
so it spun out of control very quickly
right so what can we do about it
that was the question we asked ourselves
and uh I mean there's this path
everybody's going through so we need A
New Path right we need to go through the
woods we need to create a new path
not the old stuff
no no it's a no-go zone now
we need to go to the right
not straight ahead
so
we came up with a well we didn't come up
with the five-step improvement process
the five-step improvement process is now
in retrospect
um that we can call it like that
um
but that's what I want to talk about
right now
so what is the five-step improvement
process
the first thing is identifying the most
valuable components
in your system
and when I say valuable
there's so many dimensions to it what
actually valuable means within your
organization
um it's like if you Google measure value
you will find a lot of different answers
to that question
the second step is aligning the
organization
around the target picture you want to
have
right
we will talk about why this is an
important step
a little bit later
the third step is not diving directly in
after you have you know created this
uh future Target picture but rather
understand where you currently are you
know analyze measure
and not just you know running a static
code analysis analyzer tool over your
code base I mean yes you do that as well
but there's more to it than just that
so now you have an understanding of your
current landscape you have an idea about
the future landscape so you prioritize
that by value so right now you can
actually pick the most viable component
to actually start this or pick multiple
components if you have multiple teams
working on it
but you can start with one as an
experiment you can go full force that
depends on the organization of course
for us it was a single service that we
picked
and you've finished that migration and
you go back to step four
and you go back to step four until there
is not enough value in that list anymore
right so at some point you will say
I'm not sure if we should you know
migrate that service that's used
four times a year by three people in the
organization
um but rather you know should be broader
get rid of that use case because
why should we keep it for these four
people in the organization
so let's talk about these individual
steps a little bit in more detail
identifying the most valuable components
well it's about creating new
capabilities it's about merging
capabilities it's about splitting
capabilities it's about reassessing
capabilities within the organization
right so it is repainting the landscape
of how your organization works so Step
One is a very strategic high level thing
and you will not be able to pull this
off without the support from Senior
Management or the c-level right you
cannot just do that decide this in your
team and do it
that's not going to work
the whole organization needs to be
behind that
and you need to have support from the
top as well
so
one success pattern that we have seen
that worked very well for us is Wadley
mapping
who knows worldly mapping here in the
audience one
okay and I'm gonna explain a little bit
more detail
so this is the worldly mapping canvas
this is an example for inventory
management it doesn't matter like that
you cannot read the stickies it's
important that we talk about the
different areas
um
Wordly mapping
is a method that
first tries to understand the different
value streams in your organization right
how are the different business
capabilities the business components the
business itself delivering value what
are the dependencies so how are these
value chains related
and then puts them on an evolutionary
map and what that map does we'll talk
about in a second as well
an important part as well is that you
know you anchor the value streams
on the user's needs
right you don't do it on some
organizational goals or something that's
when people talk about customer focus
that's where it's coming from right
because you want to base your value
delivery on the actual needs of the
customers so anchoring them
on the user's needs is very important
because it will transform the way you
think more into okay what does the
customer want what does the customer
need and how can we
make money with that right instead of
how can we make money and use the
customer for this but it's a very very
tiny detail but it changes the
trajectory a little bit no not only a
little bit a lot
and then you have the value chain number
five in this canvas where you know we
have the users needs and we have the
different capabilities and then we have
activities you know that contribute
to these capabilities and these
activities are you know sometimes they
are dependent sometimes they are not so
you're building these value streams for
all of the users needs you do that for
the different areas in your organization
I mean you can do that for the whole
thing you can then have separate
sessions for individual
um you know capabilities so there is
also a way to drill down
and identify these value strings
but the important part is the map right
so
we place that in the map and on the left
you see it from invisible to visible
right so the value chain starts at the
user what the user sees
and it goes down to something that the
user is not seeing right so the user
sees e-commerce
website where you know he can put in his
orders or you know his profile page this
is what the customer sees the customer
does not see fraud detection algorithms
in in the background right that stuff
that the customer does not see so
it's very detached it's important to
actually think about this as well
because the further it's away from the
customer the more you can think about
actually you know
pla building a platform out of these
things
so this map on the x-axis
has four sections
Genesis
custom
product and Rental
and commodity and utility so this is an
evolutionary scale
so when I talk about evolution
in the Genesis quadrant you're doing
something new right you're doing
something that has never been done
before for example in our case you know
uh the bus Market was liberalized nobody
has built this kind of system for the
bus Market before Airlines a lot
yeah there were a lot of airlines but
buses are not planes
buses are also not trains so
you have a very specific segment of the
market but nobody has actually built
such an application before so you are in
the Genesis quadrant here right you're
doing something very very new
a man's Mission to Mars would also be in
that quadrant right so
you do something for the first time it's
novel
um it's you know you don't have any
knowledge about how things can be done
um there is no reference point you
cannot just look up you know in some
magazine like how did others do that
um
you need to decide the way forward but
that's
on the business level right so in the
custom quadrant
you've built something and now your
competitors are also building something
right so they all built their own thing
so on on the German market for example
we had like a few competitors four or
five they all also had to build this
kind of system right there was nothing
on the market you could just you know
rent or or buy an off-the-shelf product
um like an HR software for example or
Oracle or accounting and things like
that there was nothing like that so
every single competitor in the market
has to custom build their own thing
right so that's the next step in the
evolution
so
what's product and Rental
so one cost competitor or someone
gets to the idea wait so there's
actually a lot of people using this and
custom building this so I could make
that a product right
I could actually make that an
off-the-shelf product for somebody else
to actually buy it
so that would be the next step
in the evolution right so you're
building a product for others it's the
classic I'm going to sell shovels while
you dig for gold
so that's the product and Rental
quadrant
and then the commodity and utility is
you know it's industrialized it's
commoditized
like the example would be plugs
electricity plugs right so you see them
everywhere they're heavily standardized
right so
changing
the standard of a plug in the country
just like that is not possible right
imagine how many plugs you would have to
change
in order to change that standard
there's a lot of inertia a lot of
standardization a lot of
industrialization in that sector
it goes forward like these applications
evolve and they have velocity right so
you can also estimate how fast or how
slow are these different activities and
capabilities moving on the excesses how
fast are they going from Custom to
product how fast is a competitor you
know going to come up with actually
producing a product out of his custom
built software and being then the first
in the market right so it's a market
opportunity also
so this is a tool on a strategic level
right to understand whoop
to understand
how you should prioritize your
capabilities
so another success pattern team
topologies and domain driven design
I'm a big fan of domain driven design
who here has applied to main driven
design in their organization
oh yeah quite a few
nice
so
this is a domain chart so
you have like core capabilities you have
supporting capabilities like marketing
for example or core capability which is
delivering you know bus rights to the
customer uh or a generic capability
which means okay you need to pay your uh
you need to pay your employees their
salary on time right everybody needs to
do that there is not a single
organization that says well well
there are some but they're not going to
exist very long
right and you place these also on this
kind of map but you now add the
constraint of how many people do you
actually have to work on this right so
you have let's say 175 Developers
how do you prioritize that because
that's where the money is spent on it
development right so how many people do
you attach to this kind of capability
how many people should work on this
capability what is your strategic
decision how should these teams interact
so these are all things
that yet that you can do on this level
right so it's about thinking about
how can we align you know the number on
resources and people that we have that
can work on this
on the different capabilities of course
in the core quadrant you want to have
like the best people working on it you
won't probably have spent more than on
generic and other capabilities but again
it's a strategic decision and it's a
strategic tool to help you make this
decision
because becoming faster in the core
quadrant gives you the highest return on
investment right because
you will probably deliver value to the
organization that will help it achieve
its goals
so let's talk about realigning the
organization right we have now a
prioritized list of these capabilities
we have you know switched the people
around a bit and you know have created
this kind of understanding of how these
things are working in our organization
but the current team structure is
completely a different one right the
current team structure is the one
that you know has evolved before
it's not just Tech it's also people
and we need to you know find ways of how
we can you know make the people in our
organization
work in the ways
that we need to do in the future right
carving this new path through the woods
not going down the old path but going
out down to the right
so one success pattern that we did is
the so-called inverse convey maneuver
who has heard about Conway's law
quite a few
um so what's Conway's law like the
organization has a structure with
communication you know people are
talking to each other there's teams that
are interacting and what Conway's law
said that you know an organization that
is structured in a certain way will
produce a system that is somehow equally
structured right
so the quote from Melvin Conway is this
if you have four groups working on a
compiler
you'll probably get a four pass compiler
we have three teams you probably get a
three-pass compiler if you have one team
single pass right so that's
The Core Essence of it so let's look at
what happened in our organization
it looked like that
system was [__] organization was [__] it
because you have to think of that system
was built and there is a positive
feedback loop about the system if you
think Conway's law a little bit further
it's not just a single law it's a
feedback loop because you're changing
the system
you're changing also the communication
structures in your system and that again
has an effect on the organization and
you know it's
it's a positive feedback
so what we did is you know first get the
organization
into a new structure right a structure
that we believe is following
you know the Strategic
thinking that we have applied before to
understand what are the different
activities how should they communicate
with each other right what you define is
an organizational structure right how
does our organization
so deliver value how is it supposed to
deliver value
so we are realign what we did
was we had a three-day
event where we went to Bavaria somewhere
in a in a hotel
and uh
a lot of the product owners were you
know pitching for these new components
for this new systems that we wanted to
build and you know they basically built
little booth it was like a job fair
basically right so you came there there
was this huge Hall
um and then there was a job fair with
all these
um new
things that you could join right and
they had like you know pictures and it
was very very good and then there were
some rules right so this team
needs to have at least five developers
and two front-end people and stuff like
that so you knew okay that was the
expectation and then you could go around
and see what you liked what you didn't
like talk to the people who were already
there kind of you know let the people
you know align themselves instead of
telling them
you're going to be working there you're
going to be working there you're going
to be working with that guy you hate but
I'm sorry that's just how we decided it
so rather
we thought it's better to let the people
realign themselves
it was a it was a it was a wager right
could have gone horribly wrong
but it kind of worked
of course there were some teams that
nobody wanted to work in who wants to
work in an accounting team
but then we hired new people that was
like you know that's the signal that you
get okay nobody wants to work there we
need to hire someone who actually wants
to work in this kind of team right
imagine we just assigned someone they
were like
no they would not have been motivated so
it's a signal for you as an organization
okay let's hire people that actually
want to work on these kind of things
so we did this and there's now a
constant force being pushed into the
system but this Force you know
is very weak
you cannot just do this and expect that
three months later you know your shitty
Legacy system magically like a unicorn
transforms itself into a modular
monolith right
that's not going to happen this is a
very tiny Force but a constant force
so what we have now is a map right we
have this new capabilities we know who's
going to work on that we know which
teams that have been forming so we have
this kind of map this is a map of Europe
in 1871.
um I'm I'm not saying that politically
it was the same
thing in our organization but you know
you have this alignment now right and
the teams know what they want to work on
they know what their responsibilities
are in the future system
um but now you have still the old system
so another thing that worked very well
for us was explicit ownership transfer
it's about drawing new boundaries in the
code it's about drawing that map
that we have come up with
into the existing code
so how did we do it
so yes you have two modules now right so
one module has a lot of code that is for
itself another module and then we have
these shared Parts in between and we
have these teams now that are
responsible for these modules and what
we did is we use the feature
um I think gitlab and GitHub are
providing that which is the code owners
file
so you can put this file into your
repository you can add the people that
are responsible for the subtree in which
the file is there so you could always
say okay this is the shared part these
people
are there you could also say these
people were responsible for that code
before these are the people that are
responsible now they come in together
because you also want the knowledge to
be distributed right you don't want just
want to have the new people being
responsible for a part of code and they
have never worked with it
so you want to bring those people
together
that's what's also what we did so every
time you made a change every time you
made a pull request you like all the old
owners were notified and the new owners
were notified and there was a discussion
happening right away right how does this
work and then you know the old owners
would say no no that's not right you
should you know think you'd think about
it differently like that so that was
very very helpful and it's a very very
cheap way to achieve that
so let's talk about measuring and
analyzing
it's about identifying the low-hanging
fruits
yeah this is a classic
coupling graph from a static code
analyzer but I want to
mention more than just that right so
static code analysis is one part of it
so what is the cyclomatic complexity
right what are the different numbers for
example for coupling efferent efferent
coupling uh the number of module
dependencies how big is this thing how
many lines of code are in this module
right so to get an understanding of one
part of the migration complexity and
that's the current state of the code
right so it's one part of the equation
the second part and I think even much
more important is behavioral analysis
so what does behavioral analysis mean
s
how often is the code changing which
things are changing together
which things are changed by a single
team which things are changed by
multiple teams right
this gives you an idea of you know how
the teams are working with the code not
just in which state it is right now but
you know how teams are working with it
and it gives you a lot of insights for
example it lets you understand
part of the code that are changed very
often
that are shared between multiple teams
so you can mark them as a hotspot right
because there probably you will have a
lot of contention there you probably
will have a lot of problems when you try
to separate these places so you can say
there is a high migration complexity in
that part of the system right
and I put a link on on the bottom I will
put the slides online so you can go
through the slides and click the links
and everything so that's fine it's
treating your code as a crime scene by
Adam Thornhill he also has code scene
like a platform that is offering that
you know code and that way of code
analysis also
um to you know development teams if they
need it
um but you can start very very simple
um there is a tool called uh git effort
it's in the git extras package if you
use Linux or or Mac
um where you can just say git effort you
give passive time range and it gives you
like the amount of changes you can also
add the author so there's easier ways of
how you can get started than you know
going straight to you know buying in a
license for a platform or something like
that
and the third number is risk
is revenue generation affected the scale
of operations right is it like a high
throughput low latency scenario so what
is the scale what is the operational
risk that we have there so these three
metrics together you need to find your
own weighted function of these three
things for your organization to make
sense right I'm not saying this is the
function you should use it because you
in your organization need to decide
what's important for you right now right
so we can put it on into this
kind of quadrants right on the bottom
right you have the low hanging fruits
and on the top left you have the last
toothpaste in the tube
so probably the
will never make it into the migration
there's definitely not going to be
enough value for the organization to
tackle you know a migration with that
higher for complexity
probably rather well let's let's just
kill this or re-implement it or whatever
right so don't touch this anymore
so let's get started right so we have
done everything we identified all the
components we aligned the organization
we measured and analyzed uh now we have
this prioritized list so let's get
started
so what we did is applying collaborative
Discovery to build our and redesign the
apis for the new components and for the
new systems right because you have new
activities change activities as we said
there was newly created somewhere you
know reassessed merge split so there's a
need for new apis there is a need for
new models that can represent that
so in our case we use the event storming
which is
a collaborative modeling tool
that you can use to discover these kind
of apis and these kind of models
there's other methods as well domain
storytelling
comes to mind event modeling is also
another thing that is there for us event
storming work very well because I've
been to a training before and it just
made sense for us to use that but I
don't want to you know put that on you
find what's working for you
um and try it out
another success pattern that's really
important
um tracing use case entry points and
here I cannot stress enough you should
instrumentize your application with some
kind of observability platform or open
Telemetry or something like that because
what it does it gives you the ability to
trace any request in the system that
goes through a certain module
to the actual queries it does on the
database right and if you'd have that
information you can actually
get all these entry points together that
are working with the database tables
that you deem necessary for certain you
know use case that you want to newly
Implement so you can get this list
of entry points
from the observability platform right
because we need to know where to start
we need to know like where in this
message system is actually the start for
us to go in
so most of the data most of the
observability tooling right now offers
that with jdbc you normally have a
normal integration
standard integration that tells you
exactly like which of the requests is
doing which queries
right so you can start building a list
so another success pedal pattern is Rich
models
I'm going to quickly go through so
instead of spreading this logic to the
service layer we're now putting this
logic into the actual entities right so
that's all it is that's what a rich
metal does is moving the behavior back
into the entities moving the behavior
back into the models right instead of
doing this cancel check somewhere
outside we have it inside the entity
and then the the handlers are looking
like that and you normally don't need to
change them which is getting the
Repository
and saving it and only then
are you actually starting to strangle
so
the strength Strangler pattern at least
for us
is actually not called Strangler pattern
it's something else probably the
five-step Improvement pattern but not
the Strangler pattern but let me go
quickly through because now it gets very
easy when you're at that point
right so you have a facade that is now
following your your newly discovered
apis and in our case we use the
transactional outbox pattern to
implement it and reuse the transaction
boundary that was already within the
system
and we could generate events from these
existing use cases and from these events
we could
you know
consume these events in a new service
and keep it updated
so we were in sync with the Legacy
system
of course you have to repeat that for
all of the entry points right it's not I
mean I say it's easy but it's a lot of
work
don't confuse these two things right
when I say because you have all the
information you know where to go but
it's still a lot of work
so now what you do when you have a sync
between them you reverse the direction
right so instead of
talking to the Legacy system first you
talk to the remote client there's other
intermediate steps that you can take for
example having a feature flag that uh
calls both of these things compares the
responses and sees like are they
behaving the same are they behaving
differently if you have a higher risk
you can you know add more but since you
added this facade with a new you know
interface in front of it you can have
any abstractions any implementation
behind it feature Flags whatever you're
very free to add things behind these
facets
and then you use the new service the
service puts it onto your queue you have
this order event and now the Legacy
system is sinking
the order event
and gets updated and this will run for
quite some time don't get me wrong you
have probably bi reporting analysis
inside your organization that will
depend on you know data from the Legacy
system for quite some time so this
synchronization is not something that
will just you know it's two weeks and
then we remove it so there's probably
um there needs to be a process defined
of how can we get the reporting up for
the new structures
it's also not an easy task so expect
that to be there for a little bit longer
well you're done you do now pick the
next thing you go back to step four and
you repeat until you believe it's not
valuable anymore
so
to summarize we start with a strategic
you know assessment
and Define a new map
power Organization for our capabilities
we realign the organization Acro around
this new Target picture
we measure and understand the current
situation that we're in right now
to make appropriate decisions
then we design our new apis that we have
discovered in the sessions before
we Leverage The observability platforms
to understand okay how are these use
cases coming together
and then we tackle each of these points
with a Strangler facade implementation
sounds simple
right
so that's it I think an hour is gone I
could talk a lot more about it but I had
to make a
you know to cut it short
for some so if you want to know more
grab me later thank you very much
[Applause]